وينضم إليّ الآن الدكتور ديل فيشر
رئيس شبكة الاستجابة للتنبيه لتفشي المرض التابعة لمنظمة الصحة العالمية ،
شكرًا لك سيدي على التحدث إلينا مرحبًا
روزماري ،
لذلك بالطبع نعلم أن الفيروسات تتحور
وهذا ما يفعلونه ، ما
مدى قلقك بشأن ظهور هذا
المتغير السري
الجديد  في المملكة المتحدة وفي أي مكان آخر
وهل يبالغ الناس في
رد فعلهم أم أن هذا هو بالضبط ما
يجب أن يحدث في هذا الموقف
أه أعتقد أن الإجابة في
سؤالك في الواقع هي إكليل الجبل ليست
غير متوقعة بشكل خاص
طفرات أم تحدث أه بالطبع نحن
قلقون عندما نرى  شيء
ربما يكون مفاجئًا بعض الشيء في هذه
السلالة المعينة قد
حصلت على الكثير من الطفرات في جزء مهم
من الفيروس ،
لذا فهي في الحقيقة تذكرنا
بالإجراءات الأساسية ولماذا
اليقظة أمر بالغ الأهمية والبلدان التي
نراها بالطبع  هذا أنهم
يضعون حظر السفر من وإلى المملكة المتحدة
ودول أخرى
وقد يكون لذلك عواقب وخيمة
من حيث
الإمدادات الغذائية هي أن الطريقة الصحيحة
للذهاب ، يجب أن يتم تنفيذ حظر السفر
أو هل يحتاج الأشخاص فقط إلى
الجلوس والتقاط الأنفاس
وارتداء الأقنعة واتباع جميع
التعليمات التي طلب
منا من والخدمات الصحية الأخرى
القيام بها
مرة أخرى  الإجابات في السؤال ليست على
محمل الجد ،
فأنا لست مؤيدًا لحظر السفر الذي
أجمعه معظمهم في الحقيقة لمدة
48 ساعة فقط ، لذلك ربما
يأخذون هذا الاستراحة الذي تتحدث
عنه أثناء
إعادة تجميعهم  وفكر في الأمر ، ولكن
تم التعرف على هذه الطفرات لأول مرة
في أواخر سبتمبر في الواقع آه
في لندن أه ، وقد تم
تحديدها الآن في الجينومات التي تم
تحليلها حوالي 1600 مرة
في ولاية كينت في لندن ،
وهناك عدد قليل من
الأماكن في الخارج أه أعتقد هولندا و
لقد رأته أستراليا أيضًا ،
لذا أعتقد أنه إذا بدأنا في إجراء المزيد من
المراقبة الجينية في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
فمن المحتمل أن نرى
أنه بهذا المعنى ، فإن القطة خارج الحقيبة
، نعم ، وأتذكر أننا أبلغنا عن بعض
عدت
عن طفرة أظهرت أنها كانت
أكثر معدية ولكنها أقل فتكًا ، ولا
نعرف ما إذا كانت
هذه الطفرة أقل فتكًا في هذه المرحلة لأن
الدراسات لم يتم إجراؤها
ولكن هل يمكننا افتراض هذا الافتراض بأن
هذا يبدو أنه الطريقة  الطفرات
التي
يسهل نقلها من مضيف إلى مضيف ولكن
ليس بشكل قاتل لأن هذه
الطفرات المعينة
موجودة في جزء أأ من بروتين سبايك
يسمى مجال ربط المستقبلات ،
لذلك نتوقع ذلك في الواقع إذا كان
سيكون له أي تأثير
سيكون  على
أه يمكن أن تكون القابلية للانتقال أه
أقل
ولكن لأننا نرى هذا
النسب أه بالتحديد أه يتكاثر خلال
الأسابيع الأربعة الماضية ،
فهذا هو المكان الذي يأتي فيه الافتراض
بأن هذا أكثر قابلية للانتقال
ولكنك تعلم أن لا شيء تغير
بهذا المعنى
جذور الانتقال هي نفسها ،
قد يكون الاختلاف الوحيد إذا كان أكثر قابلية
للانتقال
هو أن الفيروس سيكون أقل
تسامحًا على ما أعتقد وإذا كان هناك
ضمني ضعيف  ستلاحظ انتشار
التدخلات بعد ذلك ،
لكن التدخلات المنفذة جيدًا
أه سواء كان الأمر يتعلق
بإبعاد الأقنعة عن تتبع جهات الاتصال
التي لا يزالون يعملون بها